Das ist klar.
Guten Tag, so mas ist mein Name.
Ich bin hier aus Asistan, Arschdientätig.
Ich würde Ihnen mit Annamnes Gespräch führen.
Vor dem Gespräch möchte ich Personal erfahren.
Ist das für Sie in Ordnung?
Ja, natürlich. Meine Personalien, ja, die gebe ich Ihnen gerne.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Sylvia Hammers.
Sylvia Hammers.
Frau Hammers, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
61 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1., 3. 59.
59.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 168.
Ich bin 162 Jahre alt.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 74 kg.
Frau Hammers, was schwer beschwarten haben Sie?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich habe solche Kopfschmerzen.
Wissen Sie?
Seit 3 Tagen sind es immer schlimmer.
Das ist so unangenehm,
dass ich das nicht mehr ausgehalten habe.
Und zwar pocht das so in der Schlefenregion.
Auf beiden Seiten richtig heftig.
Und ja, im Laufe des Tages wird das immer schlimmer.
Und nachts kann ich wirklich nicht mehr gut schlafen.
Und gestern Abend ist mir dann auch etwas aufgefallen,
dass ich so ein bisschen Seelstörung habe.
Dass das so flimmert vor meinen Augen.
Und das ist so ein bisschen schlimmer.
Das ist so ein bisschen schlimmer.
Das flimmert vor meinen Augen.
Und ja, ich habe, weil ich bekannt ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe,
habe ich dann mal Blutdruck gemessen.
Und vor ein paar Tagen war der bei 150 zu 80.
Das ist ja schon nicht so toll.
Aber heute Morgen war der bei 180 zu 90.
Und da habe ich dann gedacht,
jetzt muss ich doch mal zum Arzt gehen.
Ich habe sehr gut entschieden.
Frau Hammers, sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Ja, wenn das anfängt, kriegt man ja immer nicht so mit.
Ich glaube, sie sind ja plötzlich aufgetreten.
Und dann sind sie nicht wieder weggegangen,
sondern irgendwie immer schlimmer geworden.
Und die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Ja, okay.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Sie haben schon gesagt, poh.
Aber können Sie mehr beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher blumf, ziehend oder klopp?
Ja, klopp, find ihr.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzschule
von 1 bis 2?
Ja, klopp, find ihr.
Also, jetzt am Abend sind die bestimmt bei 8.
Amor, das klingt sehr stark.
Ja, soll es Ihnen Schmerzmittel geben?
Ja, wenn das jetzt nicht so lange dauert,
ich laufe ja schon 3 Tage damit rum.
Ja, okay.
Aber können Sie mir nachher gerne etwas geben?
Aber jetzt für den Augenblick halte ich das,
glaube ich, noch nicht.
Morgen sind die Schmerzen nicht ganz so schlimm.
Da sind sie vielleicht sobald 6.
6, ja.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente unter den Augen.
Ich habe versucht, Ibuprofen zu nehmen.
Aber das hat mich eigentlich viel geändert.
Nicht geändert?
Nein.
Ich trage der Schmerz in andere Körperstärken,
aber ich habe es nicht geändert.
Ich trage es in andere Körperstärken, glaube ich.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Das ist eigentlich so beschränkt auf den Schläfenbereich, ja.
Nein.
Aber beidseits.
Beidseits. Haben Sie auch Nackenschmerzen?
Ne, Nackenschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber ich glaube nicht.
Ist die dann?
Ist die dann über?
Übel ist mir auch nicht.
Ne, muss ich die Erbruch sein?
Ne, ne, ne.
Okay, sehr gut.
Okay.
Frau Hammers, Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie sehr störenden haben.
Haben Sie auch Krippergefühl oder Taubheizgefühl?
Nein, das kann ich nicht beschreiben.
Ich habe nur, dass das so vor den Augen so flimmert.
Ja, vorhanden.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Zum Beispiel Geräusch oder Glicht?
Also, ich denke mal angefangen hat das,
weil ich einfach unheimlich viel Stress habe
bei der Arbeit im Augenblick.
Ja.
Wir haben viel Schiprest.
Ja, wir haben eine eigene Firma.
Ich mache da die Buchhaltung.
Und jetzt zum Jahresende muss man fristgerecht
alle Sachen fertig bekommen.
Und ich glaube, das hat mir jetzt einfach
ordentlich Stress gemacht.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie früher auch ähnliche Schwärme gehabt?
Nein, das ist so schlimm, das kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Nein, okay.
Bekommen Sie Luftnot, Frau Hammers?
Nee, Luft, also, Alten kann ich uneingeschränkt, ja, das geht.
Husten oder?
Bitte?
Husten.
Husten habe ich auch nicht, ne.
Haben Sie erwähnt, dass Sie Schlafproblemen haben?
Normalerweise nicht, nur wegen der Schmerzen.
Ja, da kommt man nachts nicht in den Schlaf.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme auf der Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nee, da habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme.
Ja, das ist gut.
Okay.
Frau Hammers, ich möchte einige Fragen über Ihre Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie am chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, tatsächlich, ich habe schon erwähnt, dass ich einen hohen Blutdruck habe.
Das ist schon seit acht Jahren.
Acht Jahren?
Und was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ja, ich nehme Ramie Pril.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Ich meine, das sind fünf.
Morgen oder?
Morgen.
Okay.
Und dann habe ich tatsächlich auch seit fünf Jahren Diabetes.
Diabetes.
Welche Typ?
Ja, zwei Jahre Diabetes.
Okay.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich kriege Metformin.
Metformin.
Metformin 805, eine morgens, eine abends.
Okay.
Ist Ihre Blutdruck mit Ramie Pril gut eingestellt?
Ja, normalerweise schon, aber jetzt ist er halt so hochgegangen.
Ja, aber ich habe auch Stress.
Nehm ich an, ja.
Und ist Ihr Blutzucker mit Metformin gut eingestellt auf?
Ja, aber die letzten Kontroll waren eigentlich unauffällig, ja.
Ja, wann war das?
Oh, das ist jetzt schon sechs Wochen her.
Sechs Wochen, ja, das ist gut.
Wir haben erwähnt, dass die Blutdruck und Blutzucker leiden.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, nein, sonst ist alles okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich habe eine Gallenblasen-Operation hinter mir,
aber das ist minimal invasiv gemacht.
Ja, und wann war das?
Oh, das ist schon zehn Jahre her.
Ein Jahre.
Ist die Operation Komplikation noch schweilhaft?
Das lief ganz austrhein, ja.
Ja, okay, ist das gut.
Hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein.
Ja, ich bin tatsächlich auf Penicillin allergisch.
Wie äußert sich Alarm?
Ja, ich kriege so einen Ausschlag und das rührt sich die Haut.
Ja.
Und das muss ich also vermeiden, ne?
Ja, ja, bestimmt.
Haben Sie noch andere Alarm, wie Nodon, verträglich?
Nein, sonst ist eigentlich nichts bekannt.
Aber mit den Penicillin muss man natürlich immer aufpassen.
Ja.
Und, Raul Hammars, rachen Sie?
Nein.
Sehr gut.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, sehr selten trinke ich mal Alkohol, aber wirklich gelegentlich.
Und jetzt mit den Kopfschmerzen.
Was bedeutet gelegentlich? Einmal pro Woche oder?
Ja, einmal in der Woche.
Ja, das, was ich jetzt Weihnachten auch zweimal in der Woche,
aber sonst und so, ja, eher selten.
Die nächste Frage ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Oh nein, habe ich gar nicht.
Nein, sagen wir.
Ich möchte einige Informationen über Ihre Familien kennen.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Da, wo mein Vater ist schon früh gestorben,
der hat im Bergbau gearbeitet und hatte eine Staublunge.
Der ist nur 40 Jahre alt geworden.
Der ist sehr früh gestorben.
Okay.
Und Mutter?
Meine Mutter, die Lebwache ist aber hoch betagt.
Die ist aber eigentlich ziemlich gesund.
Die hat nur ein bisschen Artrose in den Knien,
aber sonst ist sie eigentlich fit.
Wie alt ist die Mutter?
Die ist 88.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, wir waren eine große Familie.
Ich habe vier Geschwister.
Und wobei eine Schweste ist tatsächlich auch früh verstorben,
die hat mit 60 einen Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Aber alle anderen sind okay.
Gesund, ja.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie eigene Firma haben.
Was machen Sie von der Gruppe?
Ich bin in der Buchhaltung.
Wie ist Ihre Familienstadt?
Ich bin verheiratet und lebt mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Wir machen zusammen die Firma.
Ich bin in der Gruppe.
Meine beiden Töchter sind schon erwachsen.
Sie sind aus dem Haus.
Sind Ihre Tochter gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Haben Sie Stress zu Hause, wie Sie belasten?
Ja, was ich eben sagte.
Diese Fristen zum Jahresende.
Da ist sehr viel auf einmal zu tun.
Deswegen ist es auch losgegangen mit den Kopfschmerzen.
Aber es wird nicht besser.
Ich habe gedacht, ich muss doch mal vorbeikommen.
Ja, okay.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Aber Gesundheit ist auch wichtig.
Ich habe alle wichtigste Informationen bekommen.
Gibt es noch etwas, was Sie mir sagen möchten?
Ja, etwas, was mir aufgefallen ist.
Seit gestern und heute bin ich sehr durstig.
Ich habe viel getrunken.
Trotzdem müssen Sie nicht auf der Toilette gehen.
Ich habe auch das schon durch.
Aber ich habe trotzdem Durst.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, jetzt ist die Frage, was man gegen die Kopfschmerzen machen kann.
Was steckt dahinter?
Was kann man dagegen tun?
Ja, meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Blutdruckentgleitung.
Deswegen haben Sie Kopfschmerzen.
Aber das bleibt nur Verdacht.
Ich brauche weitere Prozedere und Untersuchungen.
Was wird genau untersucht?
Ich möchte zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen.
Danach möchte ich Blut abnehmen.
Vielleicht brauche ich Ultraschall.
Das wird bei Ihnen Computer-Tomografie durchgeführt.
Was kann man da sehen?
Computer-Tomografie ist eine Bilkgeber.
Man kann im Kopf einiges sein.
Man kann die Macht durchführen.
Aber das ist nicht eine Vielheit, wenn ich keine richtige Diagnose finde.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Aber jetzt gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Wunderbar.
Ja, gibt es noch?
Gut, gibt es Fragen?
Ich habe Fragen, ich lese.
Ah ja, ob ich das auf die Toilette muss.
Eigentlich nicht bekannt, aber ich würde mal sagen, letzte Nacht ist ich schon auf die Toilette gegangen.
Weil sie auch schlechte Schlafen hat, weil sie Kopfschmerzen hatte und viel getrunken,
ist sie bestimmt einmal auf die Toilette gegangen, wenigstens ja.
Müssten Sie heutig wassalassen?
Ja, jetzt seit ich so viel trinke, ja normalerweise nicht.
Hat sich Ihre Appetit verändert?
Na, jetzt wegen der Kopfschmerzen geht es mir halt schlechter, es ist natürlich nicht so viel, das stimmt schon.
Hast ich Ihre Gewicht in letzter Zeit merkt, ich veränderte?
Oh nein, leider nicht, immer noch hoch.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine?
Geschwollene Beine habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie eine regelmäßige Manfrederation zu klüften?
Oh, ich bin 62 Jahre alt, ich bin weiter drüber hinweg.
Haben Sie oft Herzklöpfung, Stolpern oder Rasen nach körperlicher Belastung oder auch in Ruhe?
Hm, bei körperlicher Belastung habe ich schon so ein bisschen Herzklöpfung, ja.
Diese Schmerzen, ihre Kopfbeuge und...
Wenn ich den Kopf vorbeuge, ob die Schmerzen dann schlechter werden, würde ich sagen,
wahrscheinlich ja.
Was Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie keine Nackensteifigkeit haben?
Nackensteifigkeit, ich frage andere.
Wenn ich den Kopf runter mache, wenn ich mir die Schuhe zubinde,
oder wenn ich etwas vom Fußboden aufhebe, dann merke ich das schon,
oh, hat der dröhn Kopf, der tut noch mehr weh, ne?
Ja. Sie haben gesagt, in letzter Zeit im Krankenhaus gewesen und
was Laboruntersuchungen gemacht.
Ach so, ich war zur Kontrolle beim Hausarzt für den Diabetes vor sechs Wochen, habe ich gesagt, ne?
Aber Labor oder andere Untersuchungen gemacht?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Nein.
Oder... Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Ja, gerne.
Gut, machen... Was für Seelstehung.
Ja, ich habe das nur so beschrieben, ein Flimmern vor den Augen.
Also es wackelt sozusagen.
Beide Seite oder eine Seite? Beide Seite.
Und die Schiprachstörung, wir haben...
Aufgepasst die Schulüge.
Noch mal bitte.
Schiprachstörung.
Ist die schwer?
Ich kann es nicht verstehen.
Schiprachstörungen.
Ja, Schiprachstörungen.
Sorry. Also, nein, ich glaube, ich habe keine Schiprachstörungen.
Das fehlt mir noch.
Ja, okay.
Gut, machen wir weiter?
Ja, alles klar.
Und es handelt sich um Silvia Hamas.
Und Frau Silvia Hamas ist 62 Jahre alt.
Am 1., 3., 1950 geboren.
Nee.
Nicht?
59.
Ja, 59.
Ja, ich habe 59.
Ja, sie wollte eten.
Ich schreibe noch mal.
Ja.
Und 68 und wiegt 74 Kilogramm.
Frau Hamas hat sich bei uns...
Wir haben seit 3 Tagen bestimmte Kopfschmerzen vorgestellt.
Diese Schmerzen seien plötzlich aufgetreten.
Und seitdem immer Schlimmer geworden.
Sie beschreibe Schmerzen als klopfend, pochend und dauerhaft.
Diese Schmerzen seien im beiden temporal Bereich.
Und habe auch Selbststörungen und Polydipsi und Schlafprobleme wegen der Stress.
Sie haben keine Verbestrung gebracht.
Und bei der Patientin sei Artarelle Hipartone bekannt.
Normalerweise hat Artarelle Hipartone gut angestellt.
Aber letztes Weitag habe sie genannt.
Und das war 140, 80.
Aber heute morgens war es 180, 90 Kilometer zielbar.
Hat sie da schon etwas genommen dagegen?
Normalerweise nehmen sie regelmäßig morgens und abends damit reil 5 Milligramm.
Und bei der Patientin sei auch Gebetsmäletisch-Zweiberkannt seit 5 Jahren.
Und dagegen nehmen morgens und abends 8,5 Milligramm Metformin ein.
Sie waren beim Hausarzt vor 6 Wochen und alles war gut.
Bei der Patientin sei Penicillin-Alargiberkannt.
Die Allergie äußert sich mit Exantern.
Sie sei nicht Traublerin, sie trinke gelegentlich Alkohol.
Sie sei kolesisch-tekkomiert vor 10 Jahren.
Bei der Familienanamnese fand sie sich Stapfunge, Pneumokoniosen,
Baydäamata und Arthrose, Baydäamuta.
Eine von ihrer Geschwister sei verstarbt wegen Neocardinfarkt.
Alle 3 Geschwister seien gesund.
Sie sei Buchhalterin, verheiratet, lebt mit ihrem Mann zusammen.
Sie haben 2 Köchter und die sind Seil gesund.
Was meinen Sie denn jetzt? Was steckt denn dahinter?
Was ist die Ursache?
Meine Schardachdiagnose sind Arterelle-Hypertonie.
Was wäre differentialdiagnostisch noch drin?
Das ist die Differenzialdiagnostische, die Arachnoidal-Hemorrhage.
Sie sind die Hypertomperatur, die die Arachnoidal-Hemorrhage ist.
Sie sind die Arachnoidal-Hemorrhage.
Was machen Sie jetzt mit der Patientin?
Ich würde gerne zuerst die Monitorin schließen.
Ich möchte Ihre Blutdruck sofort messen.
Gleichzeitig möchte ich die Venöse-Sugang anlegen.
Ich würde auch gleichzeitig Blut abnehmen.
Und danach würde die Patientin habe auch Tachikardi.
Dadurch kann ich die Herzstrittmusik im Monitor gleichzeitig dehnen.
Was lassen Sie im Labor untersuchen?
Im Labor, ich gucke so als Nierenwarte-Elektroli, der kleines Bild, Blutbild.
Was noch?
Denken Sie an den Diabetes?
Ich möchte Herz-Enzyme auch.
Aber kann es noch ein bisschen näher liegen?
Denken Sie an den Diabetes?
Ja, die Patientin hat Diabetes.
Ich möchte auch Blutzucker und langzeitig Blutzucker rücken.
Das reicht nicht, glaube ich.
Wenn Sie sich das jetzt bestätigt, dass Sie eine hypertensive Krise haben,
dann machen Sie das mit Ihnen?
Ich möchte antipartensiv Medikamente geben, aber nicht sehr schnell.
Im dieser Art, wenn die Genalblutdruck 10 kungen, ist es ein bisschen gefährlich.
Ah, okay, dass Sie mich auch in den Schuh fällt.
Sie haben viel erkannt, dass Sie Stress haben.
Ich würde gerne diese Patientin, die Physiöthorie, einen Konzip veranlasst,
weil die chronische Erkrankung an imypartoni stressabbau ist sehr wichtig.
Gut, aber als Langzeitoption.
Ja, langzeitlich.
Gut, ja.
Dann gucken Sie mal, was Sie rausfinden bei der Patientin.
Ich bin gespannt, was Sie nachher erzählen darüber.
Gut, was sagen denn die anderen jetzt dazu?
Hat noch jemand Tipps, Hinweise, Ideen?
Ich denke, diese Patientin hat einen normalen hypertensiven Stand,
alle hypertensiven 150 und bei Schicht rett 180.
Ich denke, andere Krankheiten gibt.
Ach so, dass ich praktisch noch im normalen Bereich für ein Hypertonuspatienten meinsehe?
Ja, weil die Patientin nicht im Krankenhaus oder Praxis regelmäßig gewesen und Labordiagnose nicht machen.
Nicht gemacht ist, okay.
Ja, nicht gemacht.
Was ist denn jetzt tatsächlich alternativ noch sein?
Also, was ja noch irgendwie im Raum steht, wäre, dass der Blutzucker entgleist ist.
Was natürlich insofern so ein bisschen eine Schiene gelegt ist dahin, weil sie sagt, sie hat solchen Durst.
Ja.
Polis, Polarküsli, und, ja, Politi...
Ja, ja.
Ich denke, wir müssen eine und kontrollierte Diabetesemilitis.
Ja. Vielleicht kommt noch beides zusammen, ja.
Wobei, tatsächlich der der erhöhte Blutdruck...
Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich, das ist auch sehr individuell.
Erstmal müsste man ja messen, sie hat ja diese Werte zu Hause selber gemessen.
Jetzt muss man die erstmal ja verifizieren, wie hoch ist der im Augenblick tatsächlich.
Das ist die eine Geschichte.
Das kann also ja immer noch sein, dass der wirklich tatsächlich auch noch höher ist.
Also aus eigener Erfahrung würde ich jetzt sagen, wenn ich im Blutflug von 180 zu 90 habe,
dann fühle ich mich also kurz vor der Expulsion.
Weil, also ich fühle mich schon bei 140 schlecht.
Weil mein Leben doch immer niedrigen Blutflug gehabt habe und jetzt im Alter kriege ich einen erhöhten Blutflug.
Und der wird auch medikamentös behandelt.
Aber ich spüre ihn schon, wenn er eigentlich noch nicht im pathologischen Bereich ist.
Wenn der so bei 140 ist, fühle ich mich schon schlecht.
Und insofern denke ich mal jetzt für diese Patientin, wenn die nur halb so doll gestrickt ist wie ich,
dass sie sagt, ober 180, da klappt mir aber der Kopf.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie da tatsächlich so die Definitionen sind.
Was nennt man hypertensive Krise?
Bin ich zu sehr leise.
Ich habe eine Idee noch gehabt, wobei die spricht eigentlich, ja, dagegen spricht diese Beidseitigkeit.
Das ist auch hier nicht erwähnt, ist nur etwas, was ich aus meiner eigenen Krankenhauserfahrung mitgekriegt habe,
dass es das gibt.
Und zwar eine Arteritis, der Temporalartilie.
Wobei, die Beidseitig ist natürlich höchstunwahrscheinlich.
Aber wenn das einseitig wäre, könnte ich mir das tatsächlich auch noch vorstellen.
Die Patienten klagen ja auch über diese pochenden und kraslokalisierten Schmerzen.
Aber ist hier tatsächlich im Düsseldorfer Fall nicht erwähnt, ist nur von mir jetzt so eine Idee,
weil ich es halt gehört und mitbekommen habe.
Ja, gut.
Das ist eigentlich noch die Geschichte, wenn es tatsächlich zusätzlich oder alternativ eine Blutzuckerentgleisung ist,
dann müsste man halt da noch gucken, wie man das besser einstellt.
Dass man kurzfristig einfach mal über das Metformin rausgeht.
Und dann, ja, da bin ich jetzt aber auch wieder zu wenig Profi.
Kann ich jetzt nichts über Dosierungsschema sagen?
Ich habe nur etwas gelesen, von lang und kurz, schnell wirken dem und kurz
und langsam wirken dem Insulin, dass man das dann irgendwie über den Tag verteilt.
Es gibt eine Schrittetherapie.
Genau, es gibt diese Schematasche.
Die Metformin ist sehr gut, weil die Metformin nicht nur Blutsuckersenke,
sondern auch die Metformen schützen die Nieren sehr gut.
Wenn die Patienten keine Probleme mit der Kreativität in Nierenwerte haben,
dann würden wir immer angehen mit Metformin.
Ah, ja, okay.
Eingehen.
Eingehen für eine neue Therapie.
Noch mal?
Eingehen.
Für eine neue Therapie.
Auf eine neue Therapie einstellen.
Einstellen?
Eingehen heißt eigentlich, so im Dialog, praktisch ein Argument aufnehmen.
Zum Beispiel hast du ja jetzt immer wieder sehr schön auf die Sachen verwiesen,
die ich so nebenher eingestreut habe, was ich so nebenher an Infos gegeben habe.
Da hast du ja dann gesagt, sie haben vorhin erwähnt, dass sie hohen Blutdruck haben.
Und dann bist du auf diesen Punkt, den die Patientin erwähnt hat, eingegangen.
Da sagt man eingehen.
Und wenn du das jetzt völlig ignoriert hättest, könnte ich sagen,
auf meine Informationen ist die gar nicht eingegangen.
Also wenn jemand das ignoriert, dann geht man eben nicht ein auf etwas, was jemand sagt.
Aber in dem Zusammenhang verwenden wir eingehen eigentlich.
eingehen.
Nicht erwähnen, sondern eingehen.
Ja, genau.
Auf etwas eingehen.
Gut. Und sonst bei klassischerweise diese Medikamenten Einstellung,
das ist eigentlich so der Fachbegriff, dass man die Dosierung richtig einstellt.
Bis man das ausgewogen hat, dass es nicht zu viel wirkt und nicht zu wenig wirkt.
Das ist genau die Normwerte praktisch ergibt.
Das nennt man Einstellung.
Okay.
Ansonsten war das doch grandios.
Wahrscheinlich kanntest du den Fall schon wieder, oder?
Ja, ich kenne es.
Aber diese Fall kommt nicht mehr.
Ja, ich kenne nicht gut.
Ja, ich habe nur einmal gelesen.
Ja, ich kann keine Überraschung bieten.
Sie kennt alle.
Ja, ich kenne nicht.
Ich habe auch ganz etwas anderes nehmen.
Ein Münchner Fall für dich.
Damit du mal ein bisschen überrascht bist.
Ja, aber du hast das wirklich sehr schön gemacht.
Das ist sehr schön auf die Patientin eingegangen, finde ich.
Und wirklich alle.
Alle Fragen, die jetzt hier erwähnt waren, sind gekommen.
Und die Patientin hat sich auch bei dir sehr gut aufgehoben gefühlt.
Ja, danke.
Ich sage also herzlichen Dank.
Eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Können wir sagen, dass diese Patientin ein Perdachtdiagnost zum
Beispiel unkontrolliert hat, Hypertone und Diabetes mellitus und
Neuroemotional stress.
Ja, das man so eine Tiere.
Ja, drei Perdachtdiagnose.
Eine Konstellation sagen.
Ich denke mal, das kann man gut sagen.
Denn tatsächlich weiß man ja,
dass Stress den Blutdruck pusht, ja, und nach oben treibt.
Wann hat man hohen Blutdruck?
Also klar, wenn man unter Dampf ist, wenn man unter Stress ist.
Und natürlich zusätzlich weiß man auch, dass das emotionale
Veränderungen auf sich und großer Stress sich auch auf die
auf die Blutzuckerregulation auswirkt.
Möglicherweise, das, was ich unter Stress sage,
ich muss jetzt ohne Schokolade essen oder so.
Dann ist man vielleicht auch anders und den Gerät das System
durcheinander.
Ja, das sind schon so Sachen, dass ich finde schon, dass man das
gut sagen kann, dass diese drei Sachen irgendwo miteinander
verbunden sind.
Ja, passt gut.
Ja, und es ist ja eigentlich auch so eine klassische,
so eine klassische Risikofaktur, Ansammlung.
Ja, wenn ich sage Stress, Bluthochdruck und Diabetes,
habe ich ja schon mal drei ordentliche Faktoren für
Herzrisiko.
Also muss die Patientin irgendwo in allen drei Sachen runterfahren.
Ja.
Doch ich finde, ja, gut, das ist so gut erklärt.
Danke für die Tipps.
Ja, ich bin für heute top zufrieden.
Können wir auch Samstag machen?